bekämpft euch dahinter schön ich will
immer so ein bisschen also das wetter
bei mir ist gerade sehr sonnig sache ist
nur dass es immer noch bitter kalt
draußen ist hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren runde trouble in meinen will
wie immer wieder wie immer keine ahnung
ob sie heiß und ich habe wieder die
facetime reingepackt und das nervt mich
dass die mir alle daher laufen weil ich
weiß eh gleich schon dass ich total
umgekehrt werde und ich daher nicht
aufnehmen kann
und jetzt einfach mal irgendwo rein im
moment wartet muss jetzt wieder
rausgehen
ich weiß immer noch nicht wie man von
den servern irgendwie weg kommt als wenn
ich auf einem problem ein bild server
drauf bin dass ich dann quasi wieder den
joint ganz weit ich jetzt hier auf den
da der sv nic
bürgler jetzt erstmal meinen nicht
geändert die hätte denn jetzt ich mich
jetzt überhaupt mindernd ich glaube
nicht es geht los
ich bin direkt runtergeflogen müssen
auch cool kann ich auch noch nicht die
ich mal hier rein jetzt gleich wenn ich
drin bin und mich um benannt habe auch
hier ist auch schon von manolo das ist
doch kaffee wir wie gesagt eine ganz
spontane runde einfach so weil ich
gerade auf simon warte dass wir viele
biest aufnehmen können wahrscheinlich
kommt diese folgen später denn gerade
hier habt ihr schon wieder viel zu hoch
zu laden nein also ich hätte da niemand
später auch land und leute da kann ich
kann ich kann nicht ganz da man habe ich
mich jetzt umbenannt
wieso kann ich mich dann nicht mehr
umbenennen was ist denn das und diese
werde ich immer wieder rausgekickt
verstehe nicht einmal daran nevada sind
da sind also wieder mit einem spieler
klappt gerade super hier ich hasse sie
half einfach ich hasse das
warum können wir nicht einfach die
ganzen trouble meinen willst aber normal
machen naja egal dann sage ich noch mal
ganz kurz fasst stage chemie einfach und
zwar hab ich die gerade da oben stehen
aber toll findet ihr wieder zu spät
reinkommen können nicht mitmachen doch
kann ich doch kann ich okay gut es geht
los
ich werde gleich wieder direkt getötet
weil alle denken dass ich links bin
trader aber ich gehe jetzt mal keinen
parteien
ich hab die face cam einfach mal da oben
links setzen gemacht wie hat dir sonst
mal da wo ich dahin gucke ich weiß nicht
dass jetzt sonderlich besser ist oder ob
ihr das jetzt in gaildorf findet oder
irgendwie sowas müsste dir mir dann
einfach mal die kommentare schreiben
aber ich weiß es selber nicht
ich würde dir halt am liebsten direkt
über den pc machen geht allerdings nicht
weil ich da immer so einstand
dann standbein fuß dingsbums habe wo
dann das muss halt hier links neben beim
bildschirm stehen sage ich mal
damit das ganze funktioniert und was
auch ohne ellenbogen
was auch sehr viele meinten war höre ich
bin trotzdem trade obwohl ich gar kein
pass eingegeben habe natürlich was trotz
was auch sehr geil war dass viele
meinten luca die nicht sogar vors mikro
das ist die quali voll schlecht also ich
weiss nicht findet ihr die quali grad
schlecht also ich finde jetzt nicht
sondern nicht schlecht okay das war blöd
egal ich war das war jedoch gut hat er
keine waffen von daher diese nicht
geschafft wenn auch kein bogen
spezialist viele meinten hügel ist das
mikro er quasi auf nein also das ist
wirklich besser wenn man ungefähr seine
entfernung zum micro hat habe ich auch
gerade
ich hatte nur den links zu hoch den
pegel deswegen hat er alles einfach mit
aufgenommen auch jedes kleinste
schlucken was ich irgendwie okay bin ich
nicke technik okay das ist gut weil das
ist meine taktik
jetzt hat sich hier nämlich nicht jetzt
hat sich auf dem spiel jetzt bin ich
rausgeflogen
ich hasse die halb ich hasse die haie
wer hat diesen scheiß erfunden
ich hasse das einfach ich weiß ich kann
das überhaupt nicht ab ich gehe auf
einen server drauf jetzt bin ich hier
drin
jetzt heißt die kraft zum beispiel habe
ich mich oft genannt so und wenn ich
jetzt jeden moment runter gekippt werde
dann lasst dann war's das jetzt erstmal
mit problemen kommt jetzt mich so
ballweg erzieherin und alles hart und
alles wackelt und hey ich werd
rausgekickt cool ich hasse diesen chalet
wer hat diesen tag erfunden die half ist
einfach der größte kakao verden man man
man verstehe ich nicht so kommen wir
hier ein
jetzt bin ich hier drin ach das ist doch
schon mal gut dass sogar ganz gehabt ok
neben zwei bitte votet 2
diese folgen wie survival meint will
oder trouble in games nächste weil mein
will wäre ich das wahrscheinlich nennen
gibt ja schon von von bommel glaube ich
trouble in ghost games is trouble main
will zweifel games und mein gott mein
gott oh mein gott oh mein gott wie sie
journalisten die server und ich nicht
das sind gegen diese drei runden und bei
mir ist es denn jetzt hat man das aber
das ist ein spontanes wenn ich nicht
nochmal machen
das ist in skins dealer von supreme
global player kann und dann hoffe ich
mal dass es jetzt irgendwie losgeht wie
lange dauert es noch dann kommt wieder
fdp
pro halbe minute wenn man aktiv videos
schauen würde von mir und in der seed
review habe ich das ja auch gesagt
relativ am anfang das gibt es wieder
kommt weil wir nehmen jetzt gleichauf
mit klatschen gedacht und dann geht's
jetzt los und dann welcher teil wieder
hochladen
das ist jetzt halt nur eine kleine runde
die ich eben so zwischendurch machen
weil ich muss auch gleich zum in denen
ich friseur sondern zum fototermin für
meinen führerschein da brauche ich mich
noch so ein foto oder von mir am
liebsten nummer vorher zum friseur
gegangen aber irgendwie hat sich das
nicht organisieren lassen
ich weiß auch gar nicht ob ich in der
mitte laufen soll oder halt nicht
hierher kommen 150 sekunden ist sogar
weil hier zwei das eher cool jetzt
wieder die tolle kiste animationen
also ich weiß ich weiß echt nicht ob ich
das nicht alles mal abbrechen soll mit
diesen ganzen server spezifischen mode
wie zb mobile windows bei williams
sondern halt die ganze zeit genervt wird
konkreter team ich sogar schon wieder
aufregt wer als ob ich mit einem team
mache mit dem ich erstens nicht geil
wenn ich zweitens ich kenne und drittens
wenn ich gerade selber aufnehmen
denn das ist doch mal total blöd
danke meiner lieben freunde gleich jetzt
los 3 2 1
so so so so so so
ich gehe es nach den hier drauf
oder gibt mir pfeile das eher cool
erwartet wenn ich jetzt auch mal weg gut
ich weiß halt nie ob die leute mich halt
angreifen weil ich halt con kräfte beim
namen stehen hat man weil die alles
aufnahme geil sind weil das war letztes
mal sehr oft so oder dass das einfach
ganz normal ist also ich bildern immer
einen dass die ja okay jetzt geht es
sehr gut ich habe auf jeden fall zwei
diamanten ich brauche einen stock dann
kann ich mir die schwert machen dann
habe ich die runde so gut wie so gut wie
gewonnen
auf die face kann nicht irgendwo
zwischen mich oft wird das hatte ich ja
letztens schon mal gibt sie auch so
irgendwie kisten oder so glaub nicht ach
ist das schön dieses williams weiß noch
wo wir damals eine runde gemacht haben
mit der wand alles schade mit zu ganz
vielen leuten einfach damals das war
sehr schön was los in der 10 gelaufen
der franzose der welt sterben hat der
gleiche sache nicht klappt der knicks
oder nicht gar nichts
nein das ist brokkoli player der
geschützten ideen den tod ich nicht
erwartet okay du hast es jetzt was
richtig gemacht werde mich gerade
geschrieben oh mein gott erschwert
ich weiß nicht ob sie hat mich töten
können ok brokkoli player ist ganz cool
aber ich möchte eigentlich mal so dass
ich gleich behandelt werde aber scheint
choral der könnte ich locker töten
müsste ich will hier irgendwie rein
warten wie ging das noch mal man musste
glaube ich irgendwie springen muss mich
echt ein bisschen in face camp zu gucken
auch ok wo coly player ist auch nicht
wohl
ich muss auf jeden fall gegen welche
kisten jetzt kriegen sorry conny das ist
pvp ist so danke also ich finde brokkoli
player eigentlich cool
nein die weg ich brauche doch nur ich
brauche nur einen stock ja auch einen
stock dann kann mir dann kann ich mir so
ein cooles schwerter basteln durch jetzt
einfach wieder hier rein berichtet es
wird eine längere runde obwohl ich da so
lange weg lauf auf [ __ ] erst mal kuchen
essen
so so so ich muss irgendwie ganz schnell
rein weil einige nette leute von euch
haben wir den code in die kommentare
geschrieben die man hier alter hier geht
ja gar nicht runter wollen mich
verarschen mister gay ich dachte da
geht's runter toll was ist dass sie für
modifizierte mit ihr wieder mensch
mensch mensch darf muss er raus braucht
stärker ich brauche wirklich ein stock
einfach nur einen stock dadurch wird
auch schon mensch oder zumindest noch
etwas zu essen oder so dann wäre auch
schon mal was euro
da passt es da hin wo leute sind jetzt
so gut wie verpackt ja ich bin so gut
wie tot
ok ich muss jetzt irgendwie ein ausweg
sein
ich weiß nicht wie ist der überhaupt
noch hinter mir weiß zwar nicht wie ich
laufe jetzt einfach irgendwie hierdurch
und mich dann gleich oder funktioniert
hier ist überhaupt nicht hat gar nicht
ich kann hier raus ist gut laufe ich
hier lange hier rein und gesiegt
broccoli player ich weiß nicht ob es die
kiste
naja man hermann
was fressen ja auf jeden fall ein tnt
das ist gut weil tnt es finden sich hier
war direkt das heißt ich muss das nur
platzieren
ich muss das nur irgendwo hinsetzen und
dann wird es direkt gibt's jetzt sage
ich mal nämlich noch auf ich nehme sogar
noch auf cool alles läuft noch das sehr
schön
ich werde wahrscheinlich bald auch
irgendwie sondern eine vernünftige
facebook muss mich noch mal voll von
felix beraten lassen welche daten sind
eine ganz gute soll
ich brauche jetzt allerdings erst mal
ein paar kisten ich brauche einfach nur
einen stock elternrecht der beste
spieler in diesem kompletten spiel
welches wochen stockte man jetzt also
der lehrer egal ich laufe erst mal
erstmal langsam kann hier noch ein
bisschen quatschen duo pack ist 13 uhr
ich hoffen wir dass 87 irgendwie skype
ist ok
ich schaue mal einfach ganz kurz ich
musste ja irgendwie jetzt nicht
verstecken oder so ob kissel wieder
schnell ist hat sich irgendwie raus
auch lehrer und auch ich hatte fest eine
kiste auch leer
wo es hier noch etwas
hi
ich brauche definitiv ertrinken stock an
die näherin so ein holz liegen einfach
mal abbauen
die das nicht ich mache das nur in stark
ich glaube ich verstecke mich jetzt mal
ganz kurz proben und schauer
klitzekleinen moment wie pils cup und
das ist gut
in schadeleben ganz kurz ein klitzeklein
moment ob der oder das umschwenken
ob der simon gerade in skype ist oder
nicht hätten sind auf jeden fall
schonmal weitere da ist gut zum
verstecken schon mal so eine rufen
kartoffeln ach mensch die sind auch alle
alter ist in keiner krise ist einfach
was drin
er warte ich mal was man eben so
dazu fräsen so jetzt gute im kurzen
stopp der simon a2 wenn er jetzt da ist
dann werde ich jetzt relativ hohes
risiko gehen damit wir relativ schnell
aufnehmen können er ist natürlich nicht
online das letzte was er geschrieben hat
ich weiß nicht ob ich um einen schaffe
ich hoffe ich bin dann wacht werde aber
versuchen
ich verstehe ich wie kann man ist ein
open
so könnte das gar nicht dann wäre ich ja
den ganzen tag im bett und wird alles
verpennen obwohl ich damals auch mal
seine zeit hatte dass ich einfach der
belangen gepennt ab juli kann man alter
muss doch irgendwo ne kiste sein wo
einfach nur ein stock drin liegt hier
komme ich auch weiter niemand gesehen
warte ich dort jemand kurz zu halten ist
neu so wird zumindest etwas zum anziehen
oder so noch um eine maus irgendwie
verrückt
die aufnahme wurde automatisch
angehalten
hey da bin ich wieder ich sage dir die
panel ist richtig geil alle 15 minuten
stoppt die einfach mal so also ich werde
mir da echt noch mal eine andere kamera
holen damit ich das ganze dann irgendwie
weiß man was da los
ich habe sachen
alter geil com jolo hier legal ich habe
sachen okay jetzt gehe ich wirklich
risiko simon ist zwar immer noch nicht
online aber ich meine sachen hab ich
brauche nur noch einen stock alter dann
würde ich alles testen und zb ersten was
hier rum läuft kann ich ja nicht in die
hoch- oder so oder drin ist lava okoties
überall lager das wärs wenn ich nachher
wegen sonntag allerdings hier sterben
da muss es irgendwie hochgehen glaube
ich
woche geschafft
so wollte ich hier oben muss ihn wieder
hochkommen lassen was mach ich bin jetzt
auf der suche nach buckow die player ich
bin jetzt auf jeden fall besser
ausgerüstet als er hoffe ich glaube ich
meine ich keine ahnung was haben denn
hier überhaupt ich habe die helligkeit
schon noch sehr hell ich hoffe ihr sie
trotzdem noch alles weil ich sie selber
grad gar nichts mehr ich sie selber nix
ich kann ja auch nichts sehen hier ist
ein bisschen heller gestik ist die kiste
nicht jetzt auch keine kiste
na ja immer noch ein bisschen weiter
zurück fordert so ich muss jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal nach da gehen da weil
da ist ja dings hier ist ja der
mittelpunkt des ganzen geschehens
aber irgendwie sehe ich auch gerade
keine leute einfach viel erleben dennoch
zweifel dass nur im beruf ich weiß ja
nicht was das heißt ich mach mal ist ja
dein leben noch ein paar aber ich
verstehe es in form sehe ich dann kann
man versuchen sondern fettes haushoch zu
kraxeln
aber weil nachher die kisten sind ja
alle nicht so nach der schwierigkeit
aufgeteilt sondern einfach so in unserem
charakter reingetan nach erster oben
einfach gar nichts drin das wäre es
natürlich auch
ich selbst fest wo komme ich denn
hierdurch bulimie forschen
ich muss leute finden die runde wird
sehr sehr lang leute das wird eine der
der lange runde ich hab's ja schon
vorher gesagt obwohl ich wirklich einmal
kurz vorm start war kurz vorm sterben
aufgrund dessen büro coli spielers
afrika nicht durch die freiheit so setzt
in den kisten da noch was drin
april
dort wird er sehr lange runde
hog
nein leute ich muss weg
ich habe keine chance ist auch nur
irgendwie zu überleben
es sind noch ein paar minuten bis zum
deathmatch fakt da wäre ich auch total
verpacken
okay das match
nein geht weg geht weg geld weg fakten
hinter mir gehört diese alle da hinten
ihr opfer aber auch gar nichts zu essen
bekommen
nein verschwindet so will auch dem
fittesten bekämpft euch dahinter schön
ich studiere mal so ein bisschen also
das wetter bei mir ist gerade sehr
sonnig sache ist nur dass es immer noch
bitter kalt draußen ist weil oder ist
eine rot ab weil was wollt ihr denn
jetzt machen die beiden team ich glaube
die beiden team und die generelle
frieden frieden als gut
blenden und euch also wenn ich jetzt
leben hätte dann
das doch jetzt kacke
so hat der typ hundertprozentig zurück
zur küste
das ist häufig nicht mehr drin ich
brauche hätte ich einen stock bekommen
ach komm jetzt hier einfach
mastercard.com ja okay er hat aber
verdient dass er mich getötet hat weil
er die ganze zeit relativ nicht roccoli
player ich mag dich komm erst heute
wieder alle rum
egal ich gehe nein ich bin screenshot
ich hab' ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
diese aufnahme war jetzt relativ lang
über 20 minuten sind wir sogar gekommen
allerdings ist die sache einfach das
eigentlich ganz spaß gemacht weil es hat
ganz spaß man also nicht keinen spaß und
es hat spass macht simons immer noch
nicht online
weil es blöd problem mein will ich werde
das ganze auch nicht trouble in bings
ist einfach doch ich werde in meinen
willen einfach wird jetzt keine
dauerhafte reihe sein dass ich sehr oft
probleme mit dem zwischen werde sondern
einfach nur zu spontan und ich würde
einfach sagen es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich über einen daumen hoch freuen
und schreibt mir doch mal die kommentare
ob ihr mehr also spontane sachen sehen
wollt wo ich einfach so drauflos
quatschen oder ob er so sagt so ne lass
das lieber die lieber sterben packt den
1 wenn sie man jetzt nicht mehr und
kommt dann kann ich jetzt endlich
losfahren menschheit oder machen und
dann will ich sagen heute abend werden
wieder fett videos mit ich hab gespuckt
nein ich hab mein bildschirm angespuckt
haben widerfährt videos mit schiffen
aufgenommen und dann sehen wir uns
wieder wenn ich lust habe
steak